welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition and this is
one of my favorite lectures where we talk about
least squares regression and the pseudo inverse
so this is an extremely useful application of the
singular value decomposition is in solving linear
systems of equations Ax=b so we are very
very used to thinking about the world in terms
of this linear system of equations Ax=b
lots and lots of physical problems can be written
this way so this is our famous linear system
of equations and generally we're going to have
A is a matrix that's known, b is a vector that's
known and we're gonna be solving for x which is
our unknown quantity. Now you've you've
been solving equations like this for a long time
Ax=b but the vast majority of linear
algebra classes and textbooks spend almost all
of their time thinking about the case where
A is a square and invertible matrix so if A
is a square matrix then you have exactly as many
knowns as unknowns and if A is invertible meaning
its determinant is nonzero then you can compute
the inverse of a multiplied it by b and that's
what x equals x = A^-1 b that
would be the solution in this linear system of
equations. Now that's useful but the singular value
decomposition allows us to massively massively
generalize this for non square A matrices.
SVDallows us to generalize the solution of this
tonon square A matrices
and this is huge this
opens up a much much larger class of linear
systems especially linear systems that arise in
data analysis and data modelling for example in
linear least-squares regression okay so I'm
really excited to tell you about this and I
think what I want to do to start is to walk you
through a few of the different things that can
happen for non-square a matrices okay so there
are kind of two canonical cases of non square a
matrices that I want to walk you through one is
the so called underdetermined under-determined
system of equations and in this underdetermined
case generally we have n less than m and so we
have what I call a short fat matrix so it's a
short fat a matrix so it's kind of a squat a
matrix like this and then what we would have is at
all X vector times that a matrix equals a short B
vector okay so this is this is a X and B okay now
in general this system is called underdetermined
because there's not enough measurements in B to
uniquely determine a single unique solution X in
general there are going to be infinitely many
solutions X given B okay so there's not just
one solution X there's many many many solutions
X that would be consistent with this system of
equations in general now this is not always true I
can certainly cook up a really degenerate a matrix
so that this is never true for a particular be
a vector but if I just randomly generated an a
matrix that was squat and a B vector then chances
are they're going to be infinitely many solutions
X given that vector B because there are kind of
more unknowns than knowns okay there's there's
more degrees of freedom and X there's not enough
values in B to uniquely determine all of the
values of X good so that that's one case the other
case we think about a lot is the overdetermined
and so we're going to think a lot about kind of
under and over determined systems of equations in
this case n is larger than M and so now we have a
tall skinny let's let's actually write that out we
have a tall skinny matrix a and we're gonna write
that essentially as this tall skinny a matrix
it's going to multiply a short X and it's gonna
result in a tall B B vector okay now again there
will be degenerate cases there are some B values
where there is a unique solution of this or even
infinitely many solutions but in general if I just
randomly generated this system of equations some
a matrix and some B matrix in this over determined
case where there are more equations than there are
unknown values in X then in general there will be
zero solutions of this that exactly satisfy this
equation so again this is not always true but
there in general will be zero solutions X for
a generic B vector okay and that's because there
are not enough degrees of freedom in X to fit all
of these equations in general ok there's there's
too many equations it's over determined again I
can cook up examples where this is not true what
the singular value decomposition is going to
allow us to do though is going to allow us to
approximately invert this a matrix to compute
what's known as the pseudo inverse and find a best
fit X that either comes as close to solving this
as possible or solve this equation with let's say
the minimum two norm of the vector X so I'm going
to write out exactly what I mean by that and what
we're going to have
Let's assume that I have mymatrix "A".
I take a singular value decomposition soI have U Sigma V^T.
I'm going to assumethat this is an economy SVD
and I'm dropping thehats then what we can define is this "A dagger"
the pseudo inverse of A, called the Moore-Penrosepseudoinverse and I think I actually want to write
it out explicitly in the following way let's say
we have "A x = b" and I'm gonna write for "A"
"U Sigma V^ x = b" and now what we're
gonna try to do is we're gonna try to invert each
of these matrices one by one to solve for x on
the left hand side and again that's one of the
nice things about these being unitary and diagonal
matrices is that it's really easy to invert each
of these matrices one at a time. Okay so what I'm
gonna do if I want to invert this I'm just going
to write this one more time "U Sigma V^Tx ="
and I'm going to give myself some room
here if I want to invert U I just multiply by
U^T if I want to invert Sigma I'm going
to multiply by Sigma inverse and if I want to
invert V^T I'm going to multiply by V
and so this matrix here is what I'm defining as "A dagger"
the pseudo inverse that's equal to V Sigma^-1 U^T
and this is what's known as
the Moore-Penrose pseudoinverse. Because my matrix
A is not square a proper inverse doesn't exist and
this is as close as I'm going to get to inverting
that A matrix and solving solving for x and so
again this cancels to the identity this cancels
to the identity and this cancels to the identity
and so I'm left with x let's call it "x tilde" it's
kind of my best approximation is equal to "V Sigma^-1 U^T b"
which we're going to define
as "A dagger b" that's how we define the pseudo
inverse and it's technically the left pseudo
inverse because A is multiplying x on the left and
I want to invert it on the left.
If it was "xA" I would invert it on the right and I get a right
pseudo inverse.
Okay so a pretty simple idea we'regoing to use the SVD a to invert to pseudo-inverse
this a and solve for X and this is somehow the
best X we're going to get for these two equations
linear systems of equations okay and specifically
these X's actually mean something so in the
underdetermined case in this case here there's
infinitely many solutions this is the X tilde has
the minimum two norm so the x2 is minimum this is
the let me let me write this a different way we
have essentially the minimum to norm X such that
a X tilde equals B is given by this solution so
of all infinitely many X tilde is that do in fact
satisfy this this one is the solution that has the
minimum two norm okay so we call this the minimum
the minimum norm solution and sometimes that can
be useful maybe you know maybe this corresponds to
energy or something and having the minimum norm is
like the cheapest way of multiplying a by a vector
X to get this the specter B now in the case where
there are no solutions in this overdetermined
case this is still kind of the best solution we're
going to get what this does is this is the what's
called the least square solution it minimizes the
error between a X tilde and B this two norm error
so this is called the the least squares solution
so even if there is not an exact solution to this
over determined system of equations this pseudo
inverse solution X tilde equals a pseudo inverse
B is somehow the solution that minimizes the
error in the fit between ax and B so even if
I can't exactly find an X that a times x equals B
this is going to be the one that has the minimum
to nor impossible the least squares solution and
this is the cornerstone of linear least squares
regression we're going to talk a lot about that
in the next few lectures but I really wanted to
just point out that you have now the power of
generalizing these linear systems of equations
to non square matrices a and we compute instead
of the inverse the pseudo inverse using the SVD
and that solution that you get when you solve for
x has these very nice optimal properties they're
either the minimum norm solution that satisfies
the system or the least square solution that
satisfies the system okay so we'll talk more
about this in the next few lectures thank you